en un primer vistazo esta página se
parece inconfundiblemente a la del
Ministerio de asuntos exteriores Francés
pero si se ve más de cerca se descubre
que es falsa casi una réplica que forma
parte de una campaña de desinformación
de Rusia
las autoridades francesas han
descubierto una importante campaña de
desinformación rusa con noticias falsas
hostiles a Ucrania hechas para que
parecieran publicadas por destacados
medios de comunicación franceses
le monta afirma que los agentes que
crearon y difundieron esta falsa página
web también están detrás de numerosas
imitaciones de periódicos franceses como
le parecían y Ben minute así como de
importantes medios alemanes como deads
también han circulado imitaciones
similares en Italia y el Reino Unido en
medio de la creciente preocupación por
las campañas de desinformación rusas en
los países occidentales el modus
operandi es el mismo un artículo falso
por Moscú criticando al presidente
ucraniano voló de mirza lens ky por
ejemplo o denunciando las sanciones
contra Rusia además de impulsar el
discurso del crimen las campañas parecen
tener el objetivo secundario de hacer
creer que existe un apoyo Popular a
Rusia dentro de la Unión Europea la
ministra francesa de asuntos exteriores
ha denunciado las campañas diciendo que
Moscú intenta socavar las instituciones
democráticas e influir en la opinión
pública internacional sobre su invasión
de